you sound very lively a lot more lively
than they were in birmingham
this is the 11th hustings on our
nationwide tour and it's our penultimate
outing
and believe me the production team and
me and all the people who've been all
the time we're getting a bit giddy now
it's good to be here in our eastern
region
and to welcome your regional chairman
colin noble
these hustings are for us
the members of the conservative party to
take part in a great exercise of
democracy where we get to choose our new
leader
she or he will be announced on the 5th
of september
and as with the party of government then
will become prime minister very soon
afterwards
as ian dale who moderated many of these
hustings in 2019 said
i found chairing the hustings a
surprisingly positive experience
the members really put the two
candidates through their paces and asked
some very searching questions
so i ask you tonight to make your
questions searching
to make them succinct and to ask
questions and not to make statements
and one question each please so that
more of the audience have an opportunity
to grill our candidates
both of our candidates have a duty and a
desire desire to fulfill our 2019
manifesto
their differences will be about how to
go about achieving that in a very
different world from 2019
post brexit
post covered and then certain times
internationally just look at ukraine and
taiwan
and where our union as a nation is being
challenged as never before
so i'm sure that you want to test both
our candidates to seek to establish
their strengths and to see who you think
is best capable of running our great
country
and i know as conservatives here that
you'll all be respectful of our two
candidates and keep your questions
positive
there's now just over a week left to
vote
if you haven't already then you can cast
your vote online or by post
it's very easy to vote online and you or
you can choose traditional snail mail
and if you do post then please remember
to put a stamp on your envelope
and note that there are planned postal
strikes this weekend
so voting online is the way to go
you should all have received your ballot
paper and if you haven't then with some
urgency now please contact your
constituency office who will try and
help you out
my hope is that this evening will give
you more clarity about how to cast your
vote
i hope that you'll go away enthused and
energized in your commitment to help our
party win the next election we need your
help and support
finally i'd like to remind everyone that
at the end of this democratic process
we have to come together as a party
we have many new members who should be
contacted and made to feel welcome
we have members returning to the fold
and we must make use of their talents
ours has to be a combined effort under
our new leader to go forward to victory
at the next election
and now ladies and gentlemen without
further ado
let's get on with the show
please welcome andrew stevenson chairman
of the conservative party
[Applause]
hello norwich
delighted to join you for these this the
penultimate hustlings we've been
traveling around the country peter and i
and the team organizing these hustlings
we've been to the north the south the
west the north west the southwest so i'm
delighted that we're now here in the
east of england
some have criticized this process
claiming that the contest has now gone
on too long
it's true that the two campaign teams
and all the cchq staff organizing the
hustings by this point are pretty
knackered
but we're not doing this to keep the
westminster media bubble entertained
we're doing this for you
our members
because this
is your choice
conservative members from all parts of
our country deserve their chance to see
the two leadership contenders in action
and to ask them the questions that you
want answered
central office staff and myself are
remaining neutral in this contest the
choice is yours but we stand ready to
unite behind whoever you choose as our
next leader
from meeting conservative activists at
the 60 plus campaigning sessions i've
taken part in since taking over as
chairman
that's the message i'm hearing from the
party's grassroots 2.
i heard it today when i was out
campaigning with tom hunt in ipswich and
chloe smith's constituency here in
norwich i heard it yesterday in
peterborough with paul bristow
because we all know that we must unite
and get behind these brilliant mps and
all the other brilliant mps in this
region like them to ensure that they are
all re-elected at the next general
election
and because we understand
that our country needs a strong
united conservative leadership to tackle
the challenges we face
whoever you vote for in this contest
will become a brilliant leader and a
brilliant prime minister
both liz and rishi have shown their
qualities in government and during this
leadership contest
they've demonstrated the need to drive
britain forward
and take on the hardest job in this
country
they will take us forward together
continuing the excellent work done by
our prime minister boris johnson
who has shown that a conservative
government can rise to the challenges of
today
getting brexit done
delivering the fastest vaccine rollout
in europe protecting 14 million jobs
during the pandemic and leading the
world in supporting ukraine and standing
up to putin
it is a truly historic record on which
our new leader can build
the alternative of course doesn't bear
thinking about it is a labor government
a party that voted against tax cuts for
low-income families against additional
investment in our nhs against protecting
our borders
and tackling vile people smugglers
and let's not forget sakia stamina's
record and what he has worked for
preventing brexit preventing the will of
the people and twice campaigning to put
jeremy corbyn into downing street
norwich that is not somebody i want to
see running this country and i know it's
not somebody you want to see running
this country it is our next conservative
leader who can continue to deliver for
the british people leading the way in
standing up for our ideals and our
partners on the world stage
uniting this country and our
conservative party
so with no further ado let me hand you
over to our host for this evening talk
tv's julia hartley brewer
good evening indeed from norwich to
norwich uh welcome to the penultimate
hustlings as the gentleman have
mentioned uh in the race to become
elected the next leader of the
conservative party but again a small
point for a lot of people watching
online and people who get to oh well i
suppose current continue to live in this
country in the future our next prime
minister
welcome here to those in knowledge who
get to ask questions but also to those
watching at home on the live stream the
whole event is being live streamed on
talk tvs youtube facebook and twitter
tonight as you know we are going to hear
from foreign secretary liz truss and
former chancellor of the ex-checker
rishi sunak the two candidates fighting
it out for the top job of course only
conservative party members will get to
cast their vote to make that choice but
whoever they choose as they say will
face a rather overflowing entry on their
first day in office cost of living
crisis nhs waiting lists and the war in
ukraine just some of the huge issues
they'll have to deal with as prime
minister in 11 days time we will know
who has won but before those final votes
are cast tonight conservative party
members here in this room will get the
chance to ask them any questions
they want and i will also get to put
some of my own questions too
so let's get straight down to business
the first candidate you're going to hear
from this evening is the former
chancellor of the exchequer vishu sunak
but first let's hear from one of his
supporters
secretary of state for health and social
care steve barkley
well good evening everyone as uh east of
england mp it's great to see so many of
our members here for our regional
hustings in what is a pact room
and in
meeting the significant challenge
that our country faces
we need a prime minister with the
courage and tenacity
who will act decisively
and bring people with us
rishi sunuk as i know
from first hand experience is the person
with these qualities
and he has the capability and experience
to lead the country through
the difficult times ahead
rishi showed courage
when as a comparatively new mp
he was warned against supporting brexit
however he and i have both been
consistent supporters before during and
after the referendum
he has demonstrated the ability to act
decisively and deliver
in the most challenging
of national circumstances when the
pandemic struck
he was not bound by treasury orthodoxy
but instead calmly
and decisively devise policies such as
the furlough scheme and the
self-employed income support scheme
that save millions of jobs
and thousands of businesses indeed there
will be people in this room
and many more
watching these proceedings
whose livelihoods were secured
by the furlough
or the self-employment scheme
or the other measures that rishi put in
place
support that was delivered quickly
decisively
and along with many other areas such as
culture art sports protected essential
services within
our communities
and indeed whilst many now forget this
at the time unemployment was forecast
to rise to 12 percent
as a result of the measures rishi took
it has stayed consistently below
four percent
and rishi's been upfront
with the british public in the pandemic
he made it clear
that he could not save every job
or every business and in this
leadership contest
he has said out to people what they need
to know
talking about the huge inflationary
pressures that we face
and not
what they may like to
hear for we know that nothing destroys
prosperity
more than inflation nothing destroys
prosperity
more than inflation and it's no surprise
that figures like nigel lawson who
helped tame inflation once before
has endorsed rishi
and trusted him to do so again
from our time together in the treasury i
know that rishi understands
that leveling up is about more
than the north of england the east our
region also needs to be leveled up too
the super deduction tax relief has
benefited many of our small and medium
businesses here
investment in key sectors like our life
sciences and targeted support for the
hardest hit by cost of living pressures
have all been and continue to be crucial
to our region
and with his family background we should
also understands
the importance
of the nhs
including the role of pharmacies and
community services something
that i've fought hard for
and i know he personally strongly
supports
rishi has demonstrated courage
in the face of pressure tenacity and
ability to deliver at a time of national
challenge and the willingness to
communicate what needs to be done in
particular recognizing the risks
that inflation poses to us all
ladies and gentlemen it's an honor
amongst fellow conservatives to be able
to introduce rishi sooner
my values
traditional conservative values are
clear
hard work
patriotism
fairness
a love of family
pragmatism
but also
an unshakable belief that we can build a
better future
we need a prime minister with experience
of dealing successfully with huge
problems throughout this campaign he's
made the right call we should target
inflation and help people with these
massive energy costs and i know he's got
what it takes the judgment the grip and
the popular reach around the country i
hope that you will join with me in
voting for rishi
please welcome rishi sunak
[Music]
good evening
thank you
great good evening good evening everyone
thank you it's great to be with you
really good thank you for having me i
must say we've done gosh there's 11 of
these first time we've had a disco ball
i've noticed so thank you cchq brilliant
stuff look i am standing here in front
of you tonight because our country did
something really extraordinary for my
family it welcomed them here as
immigrants years ago and allowed them to
build a better life
now i was raised with a few simple
values
first among those is that family
means everything to me
and that's because
we know as conservatives don't we that
the bonds of family
are far greater than anything any
government could ever hope to replicate
now in my family we prioritized hard
work
as the way to forge a better future
and my dad was an nhs gp my mom ran the
local chemist where i grew up in
southampton and i spent all my spare
time working
in her shop
delivering prescriptions to their
patients and doing her books seeing the
power
of that small business to provide jobs
in our local community
now my parents believe there was one
thing above all else
that could help provide their three
children with a better future and it was
simple it was through education
and that's why today i passionately
believe that the best way that we reduce
inequality the best way that we spread
opportunity indeed the best way that we
transform people's lives
is by ensuring that the birthright of
every child is a world-class education
and that
in a nutshell are my values patriotism
family
hard work service
and i know as i look at you that those
are your values too and that's because
they are conservative values
and that's why i want to be your prime
minister to put those values into action
in government to build a better britain
but how are we going to do that well i
believe we need to do three things
ladies and gentlemen first we must
restore trust
next we need to rebuild the economy
and then we need to reunite
our country
now when it comes to restoring trust for
me that starts with honesty and as you
can see in this leadership race i've not
chosen to say the things that people may
like to hear i've said the things that i
believe our country needs to hear
and even though that doesn't make my
life easy it is honest and that is what
leadership is all about
but will also restore trust by
delivering on the things that matter to
people
that's why i've set out a plan to
finally start reforming the nhs
because it's not just about constantly
throwing more money at it we need to
reform it and get more efficient
healthcare out of it
it's why i want to take on
this lefty woke culture that seems to
want to cancel our history our values
and our women
it's
[Applause]
it's why i want to restore trust in our
rural communities like mine at home in
north yorkshire and yours here in east
anglia
and that means increasing the supply of
british food protecting agricultural
land and unequivocally backing british
farmers
and
and it's why i've set out a radical plan
to finally get to grips with illegal
migration because i stand here as a
product of our country's proud
compassionate history
in welcoming people to our shores
but it must be done legally it must be
done fairly
and we turn on our tv screens
and see people coming here breaking
those rules that undermines trust in the
system and it's wrong with my plan we
will finally get to grips with it and
fix it restore trust and ensure that we
have proper control of our borders
when it comes to rebuilding the economy
you all know that the number one
challenge is inflation because inflation
is the enemy it makes everyone poorer
it eats into people's
hard-earned savings their pensions
pushes up mortgage rates
now
this autumn winter i want to make sure
that we help people with the cost of
living not just by cutting vat on energy
bills but by going further to directly
support the most vulnerable in our
society and pensioners because that's
what a compassionate conservative
government must do at a time like this
but what i will not do ladies and
gentlemen
is pursue policies
that risk making inflation far worse
and last
far longer
especially if those policies amount to
borrowing 50 billion pounds
and putting that on the country's credit
card and then asking our kids and our
grandkids to pick up the tab because
that is not right it's not responsible
and it is certainly not conservative
now of course
i'm going to cut your taxes but i'm
going to do that responsibly by being
tough on public spending and by growing
our economy and that's why this autumn
i'm going to radically change how we tax
businesses in this country rewarding
those businesses with tax cuts when they
are actually investing and expanding for
those businesses that are innovating to
create the products and services of the
future because with my business
experience i know
that that's how you drive growth in a
modern economy those are the tax cuts
that are actually going to work
and as someone who is proud to support
brexit
we need to make sure that we capitalize
on it and that means finally getting on
with cutting eu red tape
that's why i came up with a radical new
brexit policy of freeport to attract
jobs and investment to our country and
put one right here in the east of
england
but we need to go further and be radical
across the board and as chancellor when
i invested in spreading broadband
to places like this investing in
transport infrastructure in communities
like great yarmouth norwich kingsland
because for me leveling up is not just
about big cities it's not just about the
north leveling up is for everyone
including right here in east anglia
now in two years time when we have to
reunite our country we have to do
something that's never been done before
we have to make british political
history in fact by winning a fifth
general election in a row
now even though that's never been done i
know that working together all of us we
can do it
but it's going to require us to appeal
to swing voters everywhere
in the north and the south in rural
areas urban areas liberal areas labor
areas brexit areas remain areas in wales
and in scotland and i passionately
believe in the evidence supports that i
and the candidate that offers our party
the best opportunity
of beating labour and ensuring that kia
starmer never walks through the door of
number 10 downing street
in conclusion i'll just say this as
chancellor you saw me in the pandemic
acting radically to successfully
safeguard our economy
through the biggest shock it had seen in
300 years
now as your prime minister i promise you
that i will apply that same urgency and
grip
to tackling all of our challenges and
building a better britain a britain
where our kids can walk safely on the
streets at night a britain where the nhs
is reformed
and there for everyone when we need a
britain where our schools and
apprenticeships are the envy of the
world in providing opportunity and a
britain where our economy is the most
dynamic it has ever been with our
businesses investing and innovating to
create jobs across the nation but i also
promise you this
perhaps more importantly
that i will give you my all
to ensure that each and every one of you
here tonight can always feel enormously
proud
of the conservative government that i
will be privileged to lead
so i humbly ask for your support not
just to be your next party leader but
also the next prime minister of our
great country thank you
well we've heard from rishi sunak thank
you very much indeed to him just a
moment we're going to speak uh here from
lizard trust uh first of all i just want
to ask in this audience we can see a lot
of people with their t-shirts and
holding up their placards we know who
they are going to vote for or have voted
for can i have a show of hands for
everybody who here has already cast
their vote hands up
it's a lawful lot of you who here has
not yet cast their vote
now very interesting reaction from
everyone there as well there's an awful
lot of people i'd say the majority in
the room have not cast their vote and
other people who haven't cast your vote
how many of you are still undecided
that's a lot of hands still going up
there that shows it's still very much
all to play for despite what some of the
polls have said let's remember those
polls aren't always quite as trustworthy
as people seem to think
right so let's get on now let's hear
from uh the foreign secretary liz truss
of course but first of all let's hear
from one of her supporters
please welcome secretary of state for
work and pensions to raise coffee
friends
fellow conservatives it is my great
pleasure and privilege to introduce my
friend liz trust to you tonight
while we have been friends since we
entered parliament together in 2010
what i've always admired about liz
is her intellect her integrity
and her instinct and that is why i am
backing liz for leader of our party
and prime minister of our great country
of course here in norfolk in east anglia
liz doesn't really need introduction has
she been the member of parliament for
southwest norfolk since 2010.
fast off the block she became a
campaign-winning champion for her
constituents improving educational
attainment securing the a11 upgrade and
better trains promoting food and farming
and of course her successful campaign to
keep the raf in norfolk with make it
marum
liz's talent was quickly recognised and
used as she moved into ministerial life
in 2012
and now has served in the cabinet
continuously for the last eight years
her vast experience of a decade as a
minister is impressive on both delivery
and determination
to make things better for the people she
represents
whether in east anglia or right across
the united kingdom
that determination has shone through as
foreign secretary
in standing up to putin and his invasion
of ukraine
working hand in glove with the prime
minister and the defense secretary
even when this leadership contest
started
liz was doing her duty
going to the other side of the world to
accelerate the accession of sweden and
finland to nato
she really has played their part in
making sure that we stand up for ukraine
that shows i believe how much she cares
about duty and doing the right thing
these are serious times
and liz is a serious person who will
stand up for what is right
whether that is ukraine or indeed our
united kingdom
a child of the union she's stood up in
terms of keeping the integrity of the
union to fully include northern ireland
putting peace and the good friday
agreement ahead of our trade deal with
the eu
but knowing liz i know she'll deliver
that northern ireland protocol
she's also forged new trade deals around
the world which is to keep both growth
and tackling the cost of living
in 2019 um we conservatives through
boris johnson secured a large majority
and a clear mandate for our manifesto
but with the aftershock of covid and the
ongoing energy challenge created by
putin we now face a clear choice
on our economic way forward
i support liz and that we need to go for
growth
a combination of stopping further tax
rises and tackling unnecessary red tape
will unlock growth
that is key as well as tackling
inflation and facing into the cost of
living challenge that families face
i believe liz can do that
intellect
integrity
instinct
back liz for leader you can trust her to
deliver
the united kingdom is a great country
and i know that a united conservative
cost can unleash the potential of all
the people who make our country so great
to win the next election we need to
deliver deliver and deliver for the
british people
i know that our country's best days lie
ahead
i'm the candidate with a clear vision
for the future who can drive change and
get things done
as trade secretary i negotiated deals
with allies like australia and japan
creating opportunities around the world
for british business
and as prime minister i will continue to
deliver on the opportunities of brexit
i will lead a government committed to
core conservative principles
low taxes a firm grip on spending
driving great in the economy and giving
people the opportunity to achieve
anything they want to achieve regardless
of their background
i will work day and night to lead a
party in a government that puts more
money in your pocket and secures a
better life for you and your family
i've consistently delivered when i have
said i would
and i love our country
i want the best for us all and i'm the
person to deliver that
[Music]
please welcome liz truss
hi
it's fantastic to be here in norwich
we've traveled around the entire united
kingdom
but there is nothing better than being
back here in my adopted county of
norfolk
because in norfolk we do different
we're a county of entrepreneurs
are pioneers of mouldbreakers
we've had
brilliant successes and we've got things
done
but my friends
isn't it time
we had a norfolk member of parliament
back in number 10 downing street
i i apologize to uh suffolk and essex
members of this audience sorry about
that
now i'm not from a traditional
conservative background
i grew up in paisley in scotland and in
leeds in yorkshire
and i went to a comprehensive school
and what i saw at my school is i saw
some children being let down
being let down by low expectations
because they were from a different
background
being let down by lead city council who
cared more about political correctness
than they did about all children
learning english and maths
and being let down by a lack of
opportunities in the area
and i didn't think things had to be like
that
i wanted a britain where everybody
had opportunities regardless of their
background regardless of where they came
from
i want us to be an aspiration nation
but let's be honest we are facing very
difficult times
we have the appalling war in ukraine
perpetrated by putin
we have the aftermath of the covid
crisis
and we also have an energy price spike
we've had
two decades of relatively low growth
here in britain
so now is not the time for business as
usual
now is the time to do different and to
be different
and i have that plan
i have a plan to grow our economy
first of all
we need to get all of those eu laws off
our statute books by the end of 2023 we
need to take advantage of those
post-brexit opportunities
and we need you know that will unlock
huge investment whether it's into
agritech whether it's into
financial services technology energy
right across the east of england
next we need to cut taxes
we shouldn't have put up national
insurance we promise not to in our
manifesto and we can still afford by
cutting national insurance to pay the
debt down starting in three years time
i'd also have a moratorium on the green
energy levy so we immediately cut money
from people's fuel bills
and i would keep corporation tax low
because if we raise corporation tax to
the same level as france and 10 points
higher than ireland we're not going to
attract the investment we're not going
to attract the jobs we're not going to
get the growth that we need in this
country and fundamentally
as conservatives we need to be on the
side of people who work hard and do the
right thing
people who are self-employed people who
set up their own businesses people who
go out to work every day that's why i
would legislate straight away to stop
militant trade unions disrupting our
railways and make sure they are
providing essential services
now before i was an mp i was a counselor
and i know looking around this audience
there are many councillors i know
and as a counselor i sat on a planning
committee
and those are hours of my life i will
never get back
because you all know that you sit there
on a committee you think that you can
make decisions but you get overruled by
the planning inspector in bristol you
get told what to do by the people in
whitehall
i would immediately legislate to remove
the top down housing targets
and i would level up in a conservative
way by setting up low tax investment
zones where local communities want them
driving business growth and investment
and i'll also take on the treasury
orthodoxy the rules
that currently mean that more investment
goes into areas that already have the
investment
now we all know
it's very hard to get a mobile phone
signal near here
it's hard to get your broadband fixed
and we've been waiting far too long to
have the a47 jordan the ely north
junction built
and i will
i will take on
i will take on that orthodoxy i'll also
back our farmers
because we are one of the most
productive agricultural areas in the
whole country and what we want is we
want our farmers producing food
not
solar panels and we want to make sure
that they're farming
not filling in forms and that is what i
would do
now one of the reasons that we're facing
this food insecurity and this energy
crisis is vladimir putin's appalling war
in ukraine
what i would do
is continue to stand up to putin
and i'm proud of the record we have so
far
because we were the first european
country to send weapons to ukraine
and we put the toughest sanctions on
russia
of any country in the world but we need
to do more
i'm proud that we across norfolk
campaigned for raf moram the make it
marham campaign and we kept the
tornadoes in this county and we secured
the joint strike fighter
but we can't be complacent about our
defense
and that is why i would increase our
defense spending to three percent of gdp
by the end of this decade
also tackle the small boats in the
english channel
i i worked with pretty on the rwanda
policy we need to make it work and we
need to expand it to more countries
and i would legislate to make sure that
we cannot be overruled by the echr we
should make decisions about our own
borders
but as well as fighting for freedom and
democracy around the world
i think we need a bit more of it here at
home
and i have shown that i'm somebody who's
prepared to take on the identity
politics of the left
and i'm prepared to be honest and say
what's true
i'm a plain speaking yorkshire woman and
i'm very clear that a woman is a woman
and i will make sure we protect our
single sex spaces and what i will also
do is stand up for the united kingdom
there are too many people in this
country who say we should be ashamed of
our past
that
we aren't
the country we were that we're somehow
in decline those people are wrong
i see as foreign secretary
that people love
the united kingdom they love what we
stand for freedom and democracy and we
need to be as proud of ourselves
as others see us
now in 2019 we won a huge majority
we won seats across the country
including seats here like peterborough
like ipswich and like north norfolk and
the reason people voted for us in those
seats is it because they wanted the
labour party it's not because they
wanted the liberal democrats is because
they wanted conservative policies
because they wanted more enterprise more
opportunities personal responsibility
but what we now have to do is we have to
deliver on those promises
and i'm somebody who's shown i can
deliver
i don't take no from an answer from
anyone
and i have pushed things through
whitehall
whether it's the dozens of trade deals
people said we couldn't do
whether it's the northern ireland
protocol bill which was controversial in
some parts but will help restore the
belfast good friday agreement
i am prepared to do what it takes to
make things happen and that's what
people in britain need because when we
show that we are positive about our
country
when we show we're delivering
that is why people will support us at
the next election and not yet another
north london labour leader serkia
starmer who doesn't understand
aspiration he doesn't understand what
people in this country want
so what i would do as prime minister
is i would deliver for everybody across
our country i'd make sure it happens and
i will win the next election
in 2024.
thank you
thank you
right all very lively very big thank you
to liz trust there now you've heard from
both of the two candidates it's time for
some questions and hopefully some
answers to it's not pmq's and house of
commons we're actually going to get some
answers in a few minutes i will hand
over to you the audience here in norwich
uh to put their poses to the contenders
but very first up it's my turn to ask my
question so please uh let's uh uh get uh
some proper answers to some tough
questions some of those are suggested by
from some of my talk tv audience as well
so i've very much been looking forward
to this please welcome back rishi soon
great thank you lovely
right then right we've just got it we've
got 12 minutes we'll go to the audience
so let's get straight to it um tomorrow
off gem they're going to confirm the
energy price cap for an average home
from october it's going to rise to 3 550
pounds next summer it could be 6 000
pounds a year uh it's not just low
earners you won't be able to afford to
pay that it's going to be millions of
those hard-working families we hear that
politicians care so much about and want
their votes um the help that you and
both liz trust as well have actually
publicly promised so far isn't going to
be enough
isn't it time that you squared with tory
party members but also the british
public
that what you're offering publicly
is far less than what you're actually
really going to have to do and tell them
how much it's going to cost
well julia without doubt that's the most
pressing challenge facing the country is
something i've been talking about for a
while inflation in general energy bills
in particular and millions of families
are going to have a very tough time this
autumn winter and i don't think anyone
can say that what i've said is not
enough because i haven't put a precise
amount on it because it's hard to do
that until a we know what the numbers
are and b
once we're in office but what i have set
out is a very clear framework
for how i'm going to help people
and who's going to get the most help now
i i think we're all we're all grown ups
here we all know that in a situation
like this there's no government there's
no prime minister
who could sit here and say yep we can
make all of this go away as if it's not
gonna
feel anything no one's gonna feel
anything that's just simply not credible
i don't think anyone here believes that
that's possible that that's that's the
problem with inflation it makes people
poorer and pretending otherwise is not
being straight with everyone but what we
can do is target our help on the people
who need it most in a circumstance like
that so what i've said is the following
i've announced a lot of support as
chancellor um which is significant and
was acknowledged as being so and i've
said very clearly that i'll go further
as prime minister and there's three
people just going to be very positive
i'm just going to explain what we're
doing and then people can decide what
they would do differently or not and
that's
there is already support for everybody
that's in place
and i would go further by cutting v80
off energy bills to provide further
additional support to everybody uh
universally so that will amount to
several hundred pounds in total
but for two other groups of people i
think we should and must go further
and that's those on the lowest incomes
which covers about a third of our
country
and for pensioners people on fixed
incomes which is simply another third of
all households but those groups of
people are particularly vulnerable they
don't have the
means to fall back on to deal with it
and if we don't do something specific
for those people there's a high risk
that millions of people will fall into
destitution
now my plan is to provide direct
financial support to those groups of
people i announced it as chancellor i
would up those amounts as prime minister
they'll receive that cash in the autumn
in the winter and that's the right thing
to do and and there's a big point of
difference on this between liz and i
because her approach is tax cuts and
they don't help those people right if
you're someone working
in cabinet that's probably worth about 1
700 pounds that tax cut if you're
someone working on a reasonably low wage
it's worth about a pound a week and if
you're a pensioner who's not working
it's worth precisely zero so i think you
do need to have correct relationships
time
time is very tight what help are you
going to give to businesses because
businesses don't get the advantage of
the price cap we're looking at some
hospitality businesses and others facing
a 300 percent increase in their energy
costs already that's before they
continue to go up what help you going to
give to them because when they start
going under and closing up shop we're
going to be in a much more difficult
situation
that's that's clearly something that the
new prime minister will have to look at
you know and i'll have to look at it and
i'm happy to do so and would do so
well i think you talk about the
hospitality industry i think one thing
i'm pretty confident on is that people
can judge me by my record and it was the
hospitality industry that suffered
almost the most out of any sector during
covid and i think most people in the
hospitality industry would acknowledge
that i found a way to make sure i
supported them through it because i
recognize the value that they play in
our communities and employing millions
of people so i think they're very
important part of our economy important
part of our communities and i've got a
very strong track record in supporting
the hospitality sector and that's what i
would do as prime minister
energy needs to be reliable secure and
affordable right now our energy supply
isn't i think we can all agree any of
those um and it can't be while the
government's committed to net zero
carbon emissions by 2050 i would suggest
do you agree that net zero is an
unremitting disaster for this country
and will you abandon the policy no
i think that
uh i don't
i no i i don't think that's right and if
you look at one of the cheapest forms of
energy that we are now
using it's it's uh renewable energy
right and that's backed up by gas we
don't have the gas storage yeah we don't
have gas storage and we need to invest
in it what decision was that well i was
it wasn't mine i wasn't in government
right so
but we do need more gas storage but look
i think these two things are compatible
right and you know we have to get to net
zero it's important that we protect the
legacy of our environment that we leave
to our children and our grandchildren as
much as i care about the financial
legacy we leave them i care about the
environment that we leave them i think
that's an entirely conservative instinct
but we need to do it in a positive way
we need to in a way that brings people
along with us
and that means innovation right in a
word i talked about the economy that i
want to build i want to build an economy
that's built on innovation because the
way we're going to do it in a positive
way is by creating the new forms of
technology that will help us small
modular reactors for example that can
provide clean renewable secure energy at
affordable prices which we're developing
right here in the uk as you said new
forms of energy storage there's lots of
things that we can do that will help us
get to net zero and actually over time
lower bills and create jobs in the uk
that's my vision of how we get there but
it would be i think politically a major
mistake
for us to abandon that zero and think
that we can try and win the next
election i just don't think that that is
right okay
um
this week we saw a nine-year-old girl
shot dead in her own home amid drug gang
wars uh we also saw 300 illegal migrants
arriving in dinghies from france in just
one day indeed on the same day
we've lost control of our streets we've
lost control of our borders when did the
tory party stop being the party of law
of all order
yeah i mean i i this the story about
olivia her name was is shocking and i
was asked about it the other day i mean
my my daughter is the same age and the
thought that could happen in your own
home let alone on the streets is just
appalling and i think all of our hearts
will go out to
her family at this time now what can we
do about things like that to stop them
from happening but you're right we need
to put more police officers on the
street we're in the process of doing
that we also need to make sure that they
have the tools they need to actually
keep us safe and one thing that concerns
me as i've been campaigning around the
country is it's clear that you know
there are elements in our police forces
that are held back from doing the things
that i think they want to do that would
actually keep us safe
because of an ideology right we talked
about this wokish ideology and you know
stop and search is a good example of a
technique that works that police forces
are not always using for for reasons
that are not right and all i'll say to
you whether it comes to another thing
that we don't tackle which affects young
girls that's the issue of grooming gangs
which i've been very clear that we must
tackle and we all know why we don't talk
about it it's not right and i've got a
plan to get to grips with it but what
i'll tell everyone here is that i will
never let political correctness stand in
the way of keeping you and your family
safe that's the type of problem
in an interview with the spectator
magazine today you've revealed how the
scientists advising the government on
cobit were never properly challenged in
government there was no attempt to
assess the likely damage that would be
caused by lockdowns to health education
the economy rather obviously you said it
was wrong for the government to scare
people with their campaigns you say you
fought a lone battle behind the scenes
against many of those measures but um
why didn't you speak out publicly why
didn't you expose what was going on and
if you felt so strongly why didn't you
resign because that wouldn't have been
the responsible thing to do in the midst
of a pandemic where i was engaged in
making sure that i could safeguard our
economy and protect millions of people's
jobs and livelihoods and families from
what was going on
and and this is this is remember what i
was talking about is the lessons we
should learn
this is not to second-guess the
decisions we made at the time which were
extraordinarily difficult for everyone
involved right everyone was doing their
absolute best at the time
to do what they thought was right for
their country these were impossible
decisions but what i was talking about
was having now been through it and had
the experience of it what can we learn
from it i think government should always
be trying to learn look at what worked
what didn't what we'd like to improve
and as i reflect on that period you know
all i was reflecting on the fact is i
think when you're dealing with decisions
like that it's right to look at all
aspects of the decision right and to
acknowledge that there are trade-offs in
the same way right now we're having a
debate in this leadership race about the
right approach to managing the economy
inflation taxes borrowing and spending i
think there are trade-offs right i think
you can't have everything right you
can't
borrow lots of money deliver lots of tax
cuts inflation will all be fine nothing
will happen to interest rates and we can
help people with a cost of living
i i just think if something is you know
it sounds too good to be true it
probably is i think it's right for
leaders to acknowledge trade-offs and
that's what i was saying in that
interview that we should acknowledge the
trade-offs that lockdown had
particularly with regard to our kids
education and i think that's something
that we as conservatives believe very
strongly in education is the way we
provide opportunity and one of the one
of the most tragic things about lockdown
was the damage done to our kids
education and i think everyone in this
room would agree that we never want to
ever repeat that because it's not
something
amen to that um the nhs is in crisis
that's in crisis whether it's summer or
winter it's always in crisis millions of
people waiting months waiting hours even
to get an ambulance to get into a e
we're a first world country
why don't we have a first world first
class health service and what are you
going to do to make that happen
well i think i think the first thing to
say is
there will be many people here as there
are people across the country
that do receive
first-class care from the nhs right and
it's wrong and i i'm wrong to say that
like it's it's not as if it's not
working at all right
so
we should recognize that when it works
really well it's extraordinary i mean it
really is extraordinary when the nhs
works well that's why it's the country's
most prized public service and i think
we as a party need to always remember
that right and we're not going to win
elections if people don't think we can
be trusted with the nhs right and that's
why i did a difficult thing to to raise
money to help fund not just the nhs but
social care which for too long has been
the poor cousin but where i do agree is
that money can't be the only answer
right we're conservatives we don't just
keep throwing money at the problem
that's just not going to work we do need
to be bold and radical in reforming it
and you know i've been talking about
lots of ideas that i have to do that but
i'll give you an example of one
and that's to tackle this issue of
missed nhs appointments which we all
know about and last year you know what
15 million
missed appointments in the nhs
15 million in in
well well this is the thing it would be
it's not the biggest issue in the end
so i think you are i think you are i
think you're completely wrong 15 million
missed appointments in hospitals and in
gps so if we had a system which was
tougher on people for missing
appointments and it's not about making
money from them it's about changing the
culture so that's unacceptable because
if we do that and people cancel them in
advance what have we done we've just
created lots more healthcare for
everybody we'll get the backlogs down
quicker with no more tax pay
i'm jumping in because time is tight we
want to get to your questions but i'll
ask
i want to ask some quick fire questions
very short answers some of them one-word
answers please um 12 years in power
under the tories can you name me a
single public service in this country
that works well i thought furlough
scheme did okay
we don't have the fellow scheme anymore
what you know what i would say tell you
what works well is anywhere there's a
conservative council or conservative pcc
in charge lots of them okay
president macron friend also john fuller
somewhere over there where is he there
he is president macron friend or foe
friend police officers dancing the
macarena or investigating crimes i mean
clearly fighting crime uh mask mandates
or no mass mandates
uh yes or no is a trans woman a woman no
at the bbc tory bias or labour bias or
studiously
neutral uh there's no woke bias uh
option in there um no look i i look
there's one
no no the bbc is a proud british
institution right and it's easy to bash
the bbc in that clearly if i did that
everyone would clap and that'd be fine
but look i you know i i actually think
the bbc
the bbc is a proud the bbc is is
something that everyone in this country
is actually proud of but it's right that
it reflects the values of everyone in
this country and that is what is not
done it's not about labor or
conservatives and maybe actually it's
rural communities or urban communities
who would you rather be stuck in a lift
with kierstarmer or nicola sturgeon
gosh um
crikey i'll have to hurry you yeah i i i
yeah i was gonna take the stairs
[Laughter]
and finally if not you who would make a
better prime minister boris johnson or
liz truss oh gosh i mean liz trust we're
we're here in her hometown and
regardless of that or home area look
we've got to move forward as a party
right and i know actually
lots of you here i'm sure you know upset
with me for resigning you wish boris was
here that is not going to help us move
forward right it is simply not we have
got to move forward as a party and when
this is over like we're all on the same
team we're on the same family we've got
to focus on beating kierstarma and we're
not going to do that if we're looking
backwards we've got to look forward
right
that's the end of my set of questions
now it's turned for you here tory party
members in norwich get to ask questions
where are my microphones please uh my
microphone's there at the back um but
can we get someone at the back first of
all and then get a microphone over to
the front as soon as we can um judgment
over there yes with a white shirt on
keep your questions if you can if you're
going to say who you are and keep them
as brief as possible be very grateful
hi there i'm anthony i'm a head teacher
at school here in norwich i want to ask
you without platitudes or without sound
bites to give me one two three things
that you could do
to make the lives of particularly
disadvantaged students better in this
country yeah i so i'll give you three
things i want to do because i think
education is the most
important way that we can transform
people's lives i mentioned that in my
speech i genuinely believe it it's the
conservative way to spread opportunity
around and it's a thing that i will be
proud to spend most of my time focusing
on if i have the opportunity so look
three things we need to do first is i
want to look at the curriculum in our
schools particularly at what we allow
kids to study at 18. we are pretty much
the only advanced economy in the world
that lets our children give up maths and
english at 16. i don't think that is
probably right and i think we're not
preparing them for the jobs of the
future by doing that particularly
disadvantaged kids so i want to look at
curriculum reform at that level second
thing is apprenticeships because there
are lots of good routes into fantastic
careers these days it can't just be
about university and we need to increase
both the breadth and quality of
apprenticeships and make them available
and
and the last the last one which applies
to people from all backgrounds but is
for us to stop thinking about education
as something that finishes at 18 or 21
because now in a modern economy in your
30s 40s 50s or 60s people are going to
want to train pick up a new skill get a
new qualification to get a better job to
support their family we've got to have
an education system that is supporting
them when they want to do that and that
in a nutshell is the education system
that i want to build for you i want it
to be the envy of the world and that's a
conservative way to spread opportunity
and transform lives okay thank you for
that
all right john good evening my name is
steve uh if i could take you briefly
back to your opening speech
uh how would you restore trust
and um finally control our borders
right um right two two questions but the
two important ones yeah so look
controlling borders as i said is really
important right and
i've for those of you interested i've
got a ten point plan on my website have
a look at it there's a video there i'll
give you just a couple of things from it
in the interest of time uh the first is
we've got to move away from the european
definition of asylum because it is
simply too broad and allows far too many
people to stay here who shouldn't be
here and there's different international
legal standards we can use and i would
quickly move us to those and that will
make a big difference second thing is we
need to toughen up our foreign policy at
the moment we'll go to a country try and
talk to them about a trade deal we may
even give them international aid but we
won't at the same time insist that they
take back their failed asylum seekers
now that's clearly wrong right and we
need to be tougher about linking those
things because if we don't if we don't
do whatever it takes to fix this problem
that i will
it's costing all of us right
five million pounds a day
all of you five million pounds a day in
hotel costs for housing all these people
so not only do we need to get control of
our borders for security to restore
trust we also need to do it so that we
can start cutting taxes and spend money
on the things that we want to my plan is
online and it will deliver for you
but can i just um very quickly actually
because you asked another question about
trust which is important right yeah no
but there's they they're because you're
right very very briefly look i you know
i i think standards matter and that's
why i would actually very quickly as
prime minister reappoint an independent
advisor on ministerial ethics because i
think it sends a very strong signal and
that person should have the powers and
resources to hold people to account but
i also say this if we're going to appeal
to these swing voters that we need to
everywhere by definition they're not
ideological these people they're not
natural tories they're not natural
labour supporters what they want is a
government that works properly above
anything else and i will run a
government that is conducted competently
that is conducted seriously and with
decency and integrity at the heart of
everything it does that is the change
i'm going to bring that's the prime
minister i'm going to be and that's how
we're going to restore trust and win the
next election thank you
um can i ask you a favor
when you put your hand up can you keep
your hand up so i can direct a
microphone to you otherwise it's
impossible um would you mind waiting
this gentleman just over here with his
hand up over here with a microphone i
think oh someone over there with a
microphone anyway ah there you are
richie we rely on our armed forces in
every crisis over decades now they've
been cut to the bone
it's too late once a threat becomes a
reality
what are you going to do to enhance our
defense capabilities yes well thank you
for the question sir and you're right uh
look so i as chancellor
together with the prime minister and
defense secretary put in place the
largest uplift to defence spending since
the end of the cold war right that's my
record that's why i did we did it in the
middle of the pandemic in fact because
the threats to our country were
increasing as you highlighted and we
needed to make sure that we were
protected against those now in terms of
going forward what does that mean well
it means we need to be thinking about
our threats in an intelligent way
because the threats are not the same
ones we used to face actually we have a
threat now from countries like china
trying to infiltrate our companies and
steal technology right so we need to do
what i did as chancellor pass a law that
allows us to block that type of
investment we need to make sure that
we're building resilient supply chains
for the critical minerals that are going
to power all the electric cars that we
might be driving one day to not be
relying on hostile countries those are
the new types of threats that we also
need to be far-sighted about but when it
comes to investing in our armed forces
i i will i will of course continue to do
that if liz is here she as you probably
said in her speech she'll invest three
percent of gdp on defense now i'm not
going to say that not because i don't
believe in investing in our armed forces
of course i do and my record
demonstrates that it's just i don't
believe in arbitrary targets when it
comes to something as serious as the
security of our realm so the commitment
i would make to you is that i will
invest whatever it takes to make sure
that we keep you your families and our
country safe because that is the first
duty of a prime minister thank you
lady here i think we can guess who
you're going to vote for by your t-shirt
yeah hi rishi my name is mia i run an
alternative provision for trauma
informed and attachment-based
interventions it's not enough to just
work with education because there are
still so many children not accessing
full-time education what are you going
to do to with the social care to me to
to support families so that children
have a better start so they can actually
access education in the first place yeah
well yeah thank you for the work that
you do which obviously is transformative
for those families uh you were right
about social care to mention it you know
what people and people think about the
pressure when they hear social care and
our social care system is under pressure
and they hear that from our counselors
as well what people don't realize
actually is that half of the social care
budget in this country isn't spent on
elderly people
it's actually spent on people of working
age the children that you have a
privilege of looking after and
supporting so when i said i was going to
raise this extra money to put money into
social care it's to also support you in
the work that you do because the
pressures that our councils are under
are significant and i think all of us
want the children particularly those
vulnerable children to have the dignity
of fulfilling lives with the same
opportunities as much as possible that
all the rest of us enjoyed and that's
why i did what i did that's why i
focused also on special educational
needs funding
aided by john and his colleagues
lobbying me hard
in the budget time but it's also why in
a completely different way when i was
local government minister i prioritized
something called changing places toilets
right and these are children with
complex disabilities for whom a typical
disabled toilet is not sufficient
because there's no changing bench or a
hoist and they suffer the indignity of
having to be changed on car parks dirty
supermarket floors or not soon anywhere
and i didn't think that was right so we
changed the building regulations to make
sure we put those in i created a small
fund by saving money elsewhere and we're
massively increasing the provision of
those changing places toilets now it's a
simple practical thing but like you i
wanted those children to have the
dignity and opportunity that the rest of
us take for granted it's a very noble
aim and thank you for doing what you do
thank you very much for that
lady over here
there we go thank you thank you very
much um my name is jane rishi um i'm
very heartened to hear what both of you
have had to say about
supporting our farmers
um i've heard less about supporting our
fishermen
and obviously a big concern is trawlers
and all that sort of thing so our fish
stocks and our fishermen and i feel as
though that's one of the elements that
was a such an opportunity we were hoping
for after brexit and how can we get them
wrapped back
yes so yeah you're right um and look i
know first thing is to actually the
first thing to say is is to acknowledge
that some of our fishing communities do
feel a bit let down right i think the
first thing we should just be honest
about that they feel that they did not
get as good a deal as they were hoping
for and i accept that and i i sympathize
with it so look what i say to them is
the job is not done right now we're
going to come and renegotiate all these
quotas in a few years time and we need
to be robust about that and without
getting into all the details of with
pelagic stocks and this and the other
where we need focus like there's clearly
some specific things that we need to try
and correct because some of the quota
share that we've got at the moment and
this is getting technical for those who
are interested in this it sounds good on
paper but in reality we don't fish those
those stocks and they're not actually
there when when you when you need them
to be so look we do need to update and
the way we solve that problem is by
updating all the scientific work on
where our fish stocks actually are and
if we can do that work in advance of the
negotiation that will be really helpful
and in the meantime we created a
fisheries fund that i did as chancellor
which is supporting the community
supporting investment in new technology
kit um to help the communities become
more productive and
sorry
very briefly well look on banning trends
there's actually lots of things as you
say about fishing use also
also together making sure that we
balance the needs of things like
renewable energy offshore with fishing
needs and that is something that we are
we need to spend a bit more time on
because there is clearly a competition
for the same space and we need to manage
those things a bit better just a few
moments left um let's get to as many as
we can no no no excuse me i'll decide he
will no sit down sit down sir please can
you go to the gentleman over there sit
down
good evening richie my name is philip um
as a passionate conservative i assume
you're equally passionate about home
ownership and the right for our future
generations you have stated on planning
that you plan to ban development on
green belt this heart back to the days
of john prescott and tony blair it
didn't work then can you please explain
how your ban on green belt is now going
to deliver the housing that is
desperately needed in in her country
yeah so let me explain my approach to
this that what i've said is what i want
to
do away with is centrally imposed
whitehall impose top-down targets on
local communities because i don't think
that works i think local communities
should be in charge of making sure they
get the development right in their areas
so that's what i've said on that and
that means no inappropriate development
on green belt but ultimately local
communities will know what's best for
them they should be the ones in the
driving seat but you're right to ask at
the same time about housing supply
because most people here will have
remember what it felt like when we got
the keys to our first flat our first
home and how magical that felt and then
we built a family and a life there that
conservative dream we need to make a
reality for more people so there's other
ways we can increase housing supply we
need to densify in our urban areas
that's obvious we need to do far more
brownfield remediation and the
government's now putting more money to
remediate almost a million sites over
time and we need to do something that my
very good friend uh richard has been
talking about for years and that is to
overcome our british aversion to what we
call flat pack housing but the rest of
the world calls modular housing because
it is very high quality it is faster and
it is cheaper and thanks to that man we
are doing more of it um but but if it's
very important the last thing the last
thing i'd say is also i want to look at
the mortgage market because many of you
will in this situation who have kids or
grandkids who are paying a lot in rent
right now right and they're paying it
very very reliably and in fact they
could afford a mortgage right they could
afford a mortgage and it may be that the
mortgage payment is less than their rent
payment if they could get one i see lots
of nodding the problem is the deposit so
what i created as chancellor was a new
95
mortgage for young first-time buyers
with a good credit history and it's
working really well and as prime
minister i'd like to look at turbo
charging that product because if it
works we can help young people get on
the housing ladder much faster and then
ensure that dream that we all uh
experience can be a reality for a whole
new generation of young people because
that is what a conservative government
has got to deliver isn't it the reality
is you're not going to get more people
on the housing ladder unless we just
build more houses well that's why the
first three things i talked about were
on the supply side yeah and then we also
have but if we're allowing if
we're going to have a nimby issue we're
going to have the not here yes everyone
wants more houses just not near them
well that's why there's a million sites
julia that are on brownfield land that
we can remediate right a million sites
our urban areas are nowhere near as
dense as they could be compared to
european cities so that's not about
building on green land and either of
those things and if we take up richard's
idea we can deliver faster cheaper
housing in an incredibly beautiful way
he will show you these amazing pictures
he's got from switzerland which are
probably on his phone uh which we did
great work together actually in
government right and honestly this is
going to make a real difference to young
first-time buyers and richard deserves
enormous credit for it let's
let's take a question from a young man
over here
my name's tom i'm a member in norwich
south i've got two young children my
question is about crime
um given that 20 000 additional officers
will only take police numbers back up to
where they were in 2010
what else will you do as prime minister
to get a grip of rising crime which many
people across the country
feel is totally out of control
yeah so i mean look it goes back to what
i was saying before and that's making
sure that only do we put police officers
on the street but we give them the tools
they need to actually combat crime and
that's not happening everywhere right i
think we're quite lucky in this part of
the world we have lots of conservative
police and crime commissioners but when
i talk to police officers as i said
across the country it's making sure that
a they're freed up from not having to
deal with a lot of bureaucracy on the
one end which we now make them do which
we should strip down so they can
actually focus their time on fighting
crime and then secondly it's breaking
through some of these pervasive
ideologies that mean that they don't use
techniques which can actually solve the
problem and the last thing i'd say is
this right now
i'd give you this stat half of all
convictions in our country are caused by
a very small group of people career
criminals so less than 10 9 of all
criminals account for over half of all
the crime so no strategy for tackling
crime is is going to work unless we go
after these people and the average
number of convictions these career
criminals have is 19
right now look we're a compassionate
party we believe in giving people a
second chance maybe even a third chance
but certainly not a 19th chance right so
we need to look at sentencing for those
people because that will really help
[Applause]
final question i'm afraid from a lady
over here i believe scott's microphone
hello my name's leanne my question is
around green
um environmental issues obviously that's
becoming a big issue now it is turning
into a crisis it is a crisis for the
young generation you've not really
hugely touched on it you've mentioned
about
the sea and having wind power there
but what are you going to do are you
going to
hit big businesses um because obviously
the small people are doing that a bit
but there's only so much we can do
so i i i completely agree look i have
two young girls who are younger than you
and as i've said at these things the
only thing they asked me about and i had
been chanted for two and a half years
the only thing they care about asking me
is daddy what are you doing for the
environment and that's why i'm saying
we've got to be committed to net zero
and you heard it from me unequivocally
but the way we're going to get there is
not by hitting anybody right whether
it's big business or indeed families
struggling with bills we can't make this
about making life more difficult for
people right it can't be about well you
have to pay more for all these things or
you have to give up all these things
that you love we've got to use
innovation and technology to solve these
problems british researchers scientists
companies are going to help us solve
this problem and that's why we need to
build the innovation economy that i
talked about and i'm confident if i get
this job i can build that type of
economy and it will be our country that
leads the world in providing the new
clean sources of energy that will help
us get there so that your generation can
inherit an environment in a better state
than we found it that's what i want to
deliver for you and all your generation
right yeah you're done big thank you um
that's all the questions you've got time
for for which you see now big thank you
now i hope you here in norwich in the
hall and also those at home will
understand that i don't really want to
take a whole load of questions from
people who've got t-shirts on support of
the candidate they're taking questions
cast your vote so please welcome back to
the stage liz truss
thank you thank you good to see you oh
very good
well she went for the media double kiss
right okay so it's uh my chance to ask
questions of you before we get to uh uh
questions from the audience uh
uh same questions a lot of them as uh i
asked wishy sanak tomorrow fgm
confirming that energy price gap average
home in october from october um 3 550
pounds a year there and your bill will
be next summer could be more than 6 000
pounds and it's not just the very poor
you've talked about targeting help for
the very poor minimum wage and people
benefits they're not the only people
won't be able to afford those bills
there'll be a lot of people here who
won't be able to afford those bills um
you've probably promised some help
obviously there'll be some more help but
i'll as i asked rishi sooner do you not
have to be a bit more honest with this
crowd when you're talking about oh you
know you can have tax cuts and growth
and it's all going to be fine but
actually you need to be more modest
about how much help you're going to have
to give people and how much it's going
to cost everybody
so my my approach is first of all to cut
taxes because we currently have the
highest taxes in 70 years in this
country and that is not the way we're
going to get economic growth it's not
the way we're going to avoid a recession
and without economic growth without more
jobs without more wages we're not going
to get the tax revenues in so that is
why it's very very important that we
keep taxes low that we reverse the
national insurance increase and we also
have a temporary moratorium on the green
energy levy which will immediately
cut people's fuel bills
but you're right julia we have got a
massive issue with people not being able
to afford energy and that's base
individuals and businesses i know a lot
of businesses are struggling as well to
afford the cost of energy and what isn't
right
is to just bun more money into the
system what we actually need to do is
fix the supply of energy and the fact is
we haven't been getting enough gas out
of the north sea we haven't been moving
fast enough with nuclear we haven't been
doing enough on
renewable energy as well and we need to
do all of those things to fix the energy
problem and rather than simply saying
the answer to everything is to give out
more cash we need to look at the root
causes of this problem and that's why i
support fracking in areas where there is
support for it is why i support
exploiting those north sea gas seals
fields as soon as possible because we
need to become more energy independent
as a country and and if people think
that this problem is going to be over in
six months they're not right this is a
long-term problem and we will only fix
it by taking those difficult decisions
okay um
you talked about fracking you talked
about nuclear you also mentioned
businesses which was my next question
what are you going to do to help them
they don't have a price cap
we've seen some businesses particularly
hospitality facing 300
increases already um realistically you
can't build a nuclear power plant quick
enough to deal with the bills they're
going to be facing we're going to be cp
seeing business is closing we're going
to be seeing people losing their jobs
they then can't pay those taxes to help
fund the growth and the like that you
want to see so what are you going to do
specifically to help businesses when you
get into power early september if
well first of all it's about making sure
we're keeping tax on business low and
that is why
reversing the national insurance
increase is important so businesses
aren't playing employers national
insurance is why keeping corporation tax
low is important and it's also looking
at how do we encourage companies to use
more gas or how do we encourage energy
companies to use more gas in the short
term so it's been quite difficult for
the oil and gas sector in terms of
exploiting those new reserves in the
north sea those are the types of things
that we can bring on stream quicker than
nuclear but but my point about nuclear
is the quicker we start the quicker the
problem will be dealt with it's because
of failures 20 years ago that we're in
the position we are now so we need a
long-term plan
as well as making sure that those
short-term supplies are available
i'm not sure the tax cuts you probably
said enough i mentioned the planning
system earlier you know it is schlottic
it's taking too long whether it's
getting new energy projects going
whether it's getting transport projects
done and i'm somebody who is prepared to
crack through the system and get on with
things
people will have the final say over
housing so they're going to get the
final say over fracking or nuclear power
stations as well aren't they which case
they'll say no thank you what i support
is having more incentives in areas so
sharing the benefits what people don't
want is a housing estate plonked in
their area with no infrastructure with
no businesses with no jobs locally but
if you say to people you have the
freedom to decide what is going to
happen people do want the jobs they do
want the opportunities they do want the
new homes all right let's talk net zero
talk about energy um it is my view the
view of an awful lot i think a growing
number of people maybe not as many in
this room but certainly a lot of talker
tv and just listeners and viewers the
energy simple it needs to be reliable it
needs to be secured it needs to be
affordable if it's not many of those
things it doesn't work that's what's
happening right now we don't have a
supply that is those things and it can't
be while the government has committed to
net zero it was a decision that was made
after 90 minutes of debate in parliament
it was uncosted later philip hammond
said it would cost a trillion pounds do
you agree that net zero is an
unremitting disaster for this country
and will you abandon the policy
so i support net zero by 2050 but we
need to be a lot more flexible and a lot
more pro-business and pro-consumer in
the way we get there that's why i'm
talking about a temporary moratorium on
the green energy levy while we look at
better ways of delivering net zero at
the moment is very siloed within
government
it's not being delivered in the most
efficient way and i also support the use
of gas as a transition fuel i think gas
is going to be incredibly important
using our north sea reserves doing
things like fracking over the next few
years so we need to be much more
flexible about the way we achieve net
zero and we need to care about our
energy independence you know putin is
perpetrating this appalling war in
ukraine
and we have found out that we were
depending on spot markets for our energy
supply from around the world often
relying on regimes that aren't entirely
reliable so building our own energy
independence is incredibly important and
if i'm selected as prime minister i will
get on with doing that straight away and
of course we need to achieve net zero
but we need to do it in a
free enterprise way that is about
attracting investment into our country
not in a way that's about clubbering
consumers and businesses okay
two events happened on monday i think
have shocked at the country a
nine-year-old girl
shot dead in her own home in liverpool
amid drug gang wars we think uh also at
the same day 1300 legal migrants got on
boats and arrived in this country and
dinkies from france
also just in one day um we appear to
have lost control of the streets we
appear to have lost control of the
borders when did the tory party stop
being the party of law and order well
there's no doubt that the appalling
murder of girl in liverpool you know
i think struck us always
absolutely beyond the pale
and
you know what
what we need to do
is
make sure that we have more police on
our streets now i'm a full supporter of
recruiting the 20 000 police officers
but also make sure the police are
focusing on crimes people care about
violent crimes crimes against girls and
women's like rape and sexual assault
rather than pleasing twitter which i'm
afraid there is too much of that going
on at the moment and what
what i would do
what i would do
is introduce league tables so it's much
clearer how much time
police forces are spending on the beat
how successful they are on dealing with
crimes that affect people say that there
is much better accountability in
scrutiny and we we saw that work in
education you know when i was at school
in the 80s
people didn't know how you know there
were rumors about whether a school was
good but no one saw the figures in front
of them and i think we need to bring it
to life for people much more about what
the police are actually doing in their
area and i think that will put well yes
and i i fully support stop and search as
well i think we need to use that more
and we need to give the police the
powers they need but we also need to
make sure that they are subject to
public transparency and accountability
you also asked me about immigration you
know the issue we face the random policy
is a good policy you know i went through
all these policies i was on the
committee with pretty and others going
through what would work and the rwanda
policy
is an effective policy because it means
that people have a permanent home that
they can be in all the other solutions
to me are quite short-term just pushing
the problem around you know we need
people to have a long-term place they
can live in the problem is
the echr which is why i would legislate
to make sure the echr can't overrule the
decisions we make in the united kingdom
because that simply isn't democratic
it simply isn't democratic
let's talk about lockdown it's been in
the news today after an interview that
rishi soon after the spectator about his
role and what he felt about lockdown at
the time uh we are living audacity with
the consequences of lockdown whether
it's so the economic policy the uh all
the crisis we have there the health
service education what's going on in our
schools um did you ever at the time in
2020 2021 question lockdown policy and
it's likely costs and if not why not
well the answer is i did
i did question it i mean i was not
sitting on the committee that made the
decisions there was a specific committee
i think with the prime minister
chancellor health secretary i was trade
secretary at the time and i was spending
my time going hell for leather to get
all those trade deals over the line so
our businesses would be able to continue
exporting and be successful in the
future so that that's what i was doing i
mean
look i think when covert happened we
were all hugely shocked
and there was a
discussion about what the response
should be and clearly in retrospect
we did do too much you know it was true
draconian i think there should have been
more i don't think we should have closed
schools
no i don't think we should and
you know
i have two daughters who are of school
age and i know you know mine are
teenagers it's pretty less tough they're
more kind of self-reliant and
independent
but i know that people you know parents
and primary school children is very very
difficult and a lot of children have
ended up suffering you know
educationally with mental health issues
as a result of that and i can assure you
and this creep here today that i would
never impose a lockdown if i am selected
as prime minister
touched on the nhs there the nhs is in
crisis it normally used to be a winter
crisis now it's a summer crisis as well
every year it's always in crisis
millions of people waiting for somebody
basic treatment sometimes years people
waiting to get an ambulance just to get
into a e and then waiting outside a e
sometimes for more than 24 hours we're
supposed to be a first world country and
yet we don't have a first world
health service what are you going to do
to make it first class well first of all
you know we need to
deal with the backlog that you know
happened as a result of covert
the very long
waits for hospital treatment gpqs the
difficulty of getting an nhs dentist you
know here in the east of england the
mental health service and the ambulance
service are appalling and you know we
need to fix those problems now how do we
fix those problems first of all it's by
empowering the front line more you know
what i've been struck by going around
the country is people telling me who
work in the nhs doctors and nurses just
how many layers there are above them how
much central dictat is so even if they
have a better way of doing things they
can't do it because they're prevented
from that and i think we could have
fundamentally changed that culture in
the nhs we also had a lot of people
during covet who came in and worked in
the nhs as nurses as doctors they came
out of retirement they helped out what
could we do now to encourage those
fantastic people back in to help out
with what is another very very difficult
national situation so i'd want to look
at that and we also need to look at
issues like doctors pensions because
some of these perversities in the system
mean that we are losing good doctors but
one of the other reasons we're losing
doctors and nurses is you know
feeling demotivated because they don't
feel empowered so we have to change the
culture of the nhs in my view it's not
about more money
it's about the culture and lots of
people in the nhs who who i know and you
know talk to you say you know there is
waste you know there's waste of
prescription drugs there's waste of
resources we need to use those resources
better but the people who know are not
the people sitting in whitehall they're
the people sitting in the queen
elizabeth hospital in kingsland they're
the people sitting in a doctor's house
you know those are the people who know
best and those are the people we have to
empower okay in a moment we'll get to
audience questions to get your hands up
we get some microphones with the
audience that'll be fantastic um
my final set of questions are quick fire
short sharp answers some of them only
one word answers please uh put the same
questions to rishi sunak after 12 years
of the tories in power can you name a
single
public service in this country that
works well
well i think our education system has
got a hell of a lot better over the past
12 years and one of the last two years
well i've talked about how we shouldn't
have closed down schools but you know we
we've got better results in english and
maths more you know our gcse and exam
standards are higher okay and we have
delivered better quicksilver
we've got audience want to ask their
questions these people have come a long
way um president macron friend or foe
the jury's out but if i
if i
if if i if i become if i become prime
minister i'll judge him on deeds not
words
police officers dancing the macarena or
investigating crimes investigating
crimes obviously could someone tell the
police that's what they should be doing
um
dates or no mass mandates no mass
mandates yes or no is a trans woman a
woman no
the bbc tory bias labor bias or
studiously neutral
i don't think anybody is neutral and i
think we're all kidding ourselves if we
pretend there are institutions or people
who are neutral i'd rather have more
honest bias
who would you rather be stuck in a lift
with kierstarma or nicola sturgeon
probably i think nicholas sturgeon why
well i'd hope to persuade her to stop
being a separatist by the time we got to
the ground floor
and i just frankly
frankly the idea of being stuck in a
lift keir stahlmann strikes me as
extremely boring
do you know richard soon act said
he said you'd take the stairs
uh finally if not you who would make a
better prime minister boris johnson or
rishi sunak boris johnson
wow
interesting same question some very
different answers there uh thank you
very much that's the end of my questions
and i've got time for questions from the
audience anyone here got a microphone
right the chap over there yeah the lady
just there just in front of you lovely
if you could say who you are we keep the
questions as brief as possible we can
get as many as possible in i'll try
hello uh ruth betson i'm the eastern
region chairman for cwo and the regional
ambassador cpf
no
so for the next general election we need
great policies but we also need
activists to get out
and knock on the doors and campaign
if you become the leader of the
conservative party how are you going to
help us get more activists more boots on
the ground okay
well i've been a conservative party
member since 1996 and i've knocked on a
lot of doors i've been a counselor i've
been a constituency chairman and i think
what we need to do
is we need to
provide more support say more
professional agents less money spent in
central office more money spent on the
field so that our volunteers can be
doing what they're good at and also
enjoy themselves because it's when
people enjoy themselves when they feel
they're making progress when it's fun
that's when they come out and campaign
and that's the culture we have to create
it's obviously it's obviously very alive
and well in southwest norfolk i point
out to all the activists i see in the
audience
expert over here at the back
hi my name is dan and i'm told
tirelessly that you cannot be gay
and
support the tories
so what would you say to those people
and what are your main priorities for
the lgbt plus community
well that
that that is just absolutely rubbish
frankly and
you know
what we stand for as conservatives and
we don't stand for identity politics we
care about
your
talent your hard work
what you stand for your character not
whether you're gay or straight or
whether you're a man or a woman or which
ethnic minority background you're from
and that's why people want to join the
conservatives because they don't want to
be treated as one of a type or one of
the group they want to be treated for
the people that they are
i'm trying to avoid questions from
people who bought a t-shirt supporting
their candidate but i allowed one for
rishi so one for you liz as well this
young man at the front here
evening liz uh i'm tommy 15 year old
school student norwich uh just quite a
simple question how do we balance the
right of trans people to be who they are
with common sense the right of people to
have single sex spaces and the rights of
women to be women
this is
thanks for your question tommy this is
exactly what i did
as minister for women inequalities i
improved the process for gender
recognition to make it simpler and
kinder but i was very clear that those
under 18 shouldn't be able to make
irreversible decisions about their own
future and that we should treat
everybody with respect we should treat
everybody with respect and we should
treat people on the basis of what they
have to offer
not on
um you know whether or not they are a
transgender or or you know
not not transgender are you going to
protect um single sex bases you've
talked about um refugees and things like
that but what about you know the
changing rooms that marx and spencer's
which are currently even if you're
you're taking your child for their first
bra fitting are open to men to use as
well
i am very clear and i've made this clear
in parliament
that
places absolutely have the ability to
restrict access on the basis of
biological sex that is a very important
right
and
that should be totally true in the
public sector in schools in domestic
violence shelters now
i'm also
somebody who believes in freedom and
marx and spencers is a shop you know
they can decide their policies as they
see fit and i can decide to go in marks
and spencers or not
according to whether i want to so would
you i think
where a man could walk in
well
i i
guess would you i have been to the bra
fitting service in marks and spencers
and and it is always behind a curtain
julia and no one no one has ever tried
to open the curtain while i'm in there
um
maybe just here
hello i'm diane from cambridge here um
liz i understand that there's a long
overdue
um strategy for social care that's due
to be published this year
will you commit to that being published
and given that you're reversing the
national insurance increase
how would you actually plan to fund
anything to help social care for the
future
so on the national insurance increase
i still would spend the 13 billion but i
would take it out of general taxation
and what we saw is the obr forecast
dramatically fluctuated in fact we are
still able to do that and start paying
down the debt within three years so i'd
still spend the money
but what i would do
is push more of it towards social care
because at the moment the vast majority
has been taken up by the national health
service and in fact that's
counterproductive because what we have
is people in beds in the national health
service who would really be better
served by being in social care so i will
make sure more of that money goes to
councils to help with social care whilst
of course we deal with the long-term
strategy but it's very important we get
that money to councils now because i
know how much they are struggling with
the ability to fund social care
gentlemen somewhere over here with a
microphone lovely could you stand up
good evening bob holstrom uh just by way
of background my colleague and i
colleagues and i run 1.2 billion in the
markets my son-in-law is a gas trader
hated person at the moment obviously
what worries us
is the fact that you were going to have
a budget
and then you decided not to have a
budget
for those not in the know if you have a
budget you have to walk up forecast and
publish
a budgetary forecast showing what the
impact might be on the economy and you
refuse not to do it why not
well
there have been a number of fiscal
events this year none of which have had
that forecast i would point out look
what what's important and you can call
it a budget you can call it a fiscal
event what's important is we take urgent
action to sort out the issues we have in
this country an issue number one is we
are currently projected to have a
recession
and i believe we need to keep our taxes
low we need to reverse the national
insurance increase to make sure that we
are driving investment into our economy
and we're driving great into the economy
we also need to take bold action
to deal with energy supply and i'm
committed to doing that and
these kind of processology questions of
exactly what the event is called that is
not relevant what is relevant is i'm
somebody who is prepared to take action
to do what it takes to fix the issues
our country has to sort out the energy
crisis but also to get our economy
growing which is so vital at this time
there's a lady over here
rachel from norfolk
and i own an sme in your constituency
and we have a labor shortage in this
country but at the same time
we have
i don't know the numbers millions of
asylum seekers who are not allowed to
work and i'm confused as to why
they're not allowed to work and earn
money and put money back into society
what's that
what's your question
why can't they why can't they work why
are asylum seekers not allowed to work
when we have a labor shortage
years and years that they're they're
waiting and so we we also have
huge numbers of people in this country
millions of people who are economically
inactive and i think it's very important
that we are encouraging more people who
are currently
on the welfare system into work and
getting into those jobs and that's a
particular issue in the aftermath of
cavett i mean the reason why
we don't enable asylum seekers to work
is it creates even more of a magnet to
come to the united kingdom and i'm
determined to make sure we deal with
illegal immigration and i'm determined
to make sure that we don't become a
magnet
for
for you know
i absolutely support immigration where
we need it and i've talked about
expanding the seasonal agricultural
workers scheme to help our farmers but
where there are people in britain who
are currently economically inactive who
could be trained up to do those jobs
that should be our first port of call
getting those people into work
ladies here at the front
i'm guitar patel from cambridge chair
to prevent tax
to prevent
sorry i'm going to start again to
prevent tax cuts um
raising inflation
you're going to have to cut spending
where will you cut spending
well i don't i don't agree with this
analysis that tax cuts deliver inflation
i think it's wrong
the reason that we have inflation is we
have a supply shock
caused by covid caused by the global
energy crisis and what
i am proposing to do
in some cases they're not raising taxes
it's just keeping taxes low so i can't
for the life of bc why raising
corporation tax is going to create
inflation i mean or going to stop
inflation what it's going to do is stop
economic growth
and put this country into a recession
and
what we need to do
is we need to be growing our economy and
growing the supply of goods and services
which will help deal with the issue of
inflation so i just don't think that
analysis is right at all
all right um gentleman over here with
the microphone
hello foreign secretary james noble um
from saffron wilder now formerly
brighton chemtown um free trade was
meant to be one of the great benefits of
brexit um and of course it's got
additional benefits of reducing prices
in the shop at a time where many people
are struggling to buy food from the
supermarkets
are you a free trader or are you a
protectionist and can we have some
radical thinking on this please
hey
i i am a free trader and i have scars on
my back from the battles in whitehall to
get to get the australia trade deal
through the new zealand trade deal we're
currently negotiating a deal with india
i think that's a massive opportunity
it's likely to be done by the end of
this year we're negotiating access to
the trans-pacific partnership which is
worth billions of pounds to the uk
economy and i'm determined to make sure
we do that and we open up those
opportunities for the united kingdom and
we've got so many great goods that we
can export from this country but of
course we need to we need to deliver it
over here
[Applause]
my name is dennis um i understand we
currently import six percent of our
electricity from france through the
undersea into connectors
energy independence is clearly very
current at the moment with russia in the
headlines
would you sign the contract in favor of
edf and hand it to mr macron
for our nuclear
and
industry
well i i'm very clear that we need to
boost our nuclear industry including
size well including the small modular
reactors that are produced in derbyshire
and frankly
i would rather that we do have more
homegrown nuclear expertise and
regrettably we lost that because we
failed to do these things 20 years ago
or 30 years ago but it is if it's a
choice between relying on france and
relying on china i would take france
[Applause]
gentlemen in the t-shirt over there if
you could stand up please uh i'm in a
wheelchair i do positive all right
mistrust if you're lucky enough to
become prime minister what will you do
to tackle the current crisis in legal
aid
you've spoken a great deal about the
need for more police officers on the
streets but to my mind this makes little
sense if there's not the criminal
barristers in court to defend and
prosecute the criminals now you stood
there and said you say no
to you don't say no to
anybody but you have said no to andrew
neal why don't you go on the andrew neil
show
how are we supposed to take you
seriously if you cannot stand up to his
skepticism and criticism i don't know
about you but i think julia hartley
brewer is much tougher than andrew neal
[Applause]
she often doesn't come on my show either
i have occasionally been on your show
it is fair to ask though we do need to
have politicians who are willing to take
scrutiny and not expect soft questions i
have done many many broadcast interviews
during this campaign with all sorts of
people including nick robinson including
julia hartley bro including tom newton
dunn i mean that's pretty difficult
are we working yep hi i'm rory i run a
business in dirham
the market market towns and cities are
the hubs of our community um but yet the
high street has been in decline for
years
business rate reform is long overdue um
we're fake the high street's going to
face some challenging times
how are you going to save the high
street and support local or independent
retailers
well you are right the business rate
reform is very long overdue what i would
plan to do is have a review of the tax
system it's far too complicated we've
got one of the most complicated tax
systems in the world and part of that
will be looking at the entire business
rates system and also all the other
taxes we place on small businesses we
also need to look at the regulations
because frankly it has become more
complicated to run a business and that
is a problem because small businesses
are the lifeblood of our economy okay
just one final question gentlemen here
it's brief as you can please i i don't
like don't read the question that means
it's a bit long come on short and sharp
keep it brief okay
hello liz
um my name is sheridan
tens of thousands of qualified
experienced scientists have strongly
rejected the theory of catastrophic
man-made climate change and net zero
cuckoo land
they simply points out that the raw
scientific data has never supported
those claims this is my question if you
are successfully appointed to be our new
british prime minister
will your government finally
set up a full scientific investigation
into whether this wild theory is based
on real science or whether it is
unscientific political propaganda okay
well i mean i already said earlier that
i do support the net zero target but we
need to get to it in a way that works
for businesses and consumers and also
protects our energy independence i think
we've seen what it is like to end up
depending on authoritarian regimes and
we need to avoid that at all costs okay
let's say a big thank you natalie's
trust taking all those questions
thank you very much
thank you almost tougher than andrew
here
okay right
we we have just one more hustings to go
and that is a next wednesday that
concludes the leadership hosting tonight
i just want to ask you just finally dash
off people who were undecided at the
beginning of this evening put your hands
up if you're still undecided
a lot for you put your hands up if you
have now decided
very interesting so it's been a very
useful evening for an awful lot of
people thank you very much indeed for
coming very much appreciate that and
have a safe journey home good night
[Applause]